Now we have the kernel function given as K of x minus xn over h.
Let's say we have total number of points, capital N,
then the density estimate is given as a function of x.
Here's the normalization factor given by the number of points
inside the box with side h and dimension D.
And we sum all the kernels from one to N for each xn.
Here we can get the expectation value from the kernel density estimate.
It's all right if you can't follow along the entire math here.
The idea is to take the expectation value
of the probability density derived from the kernel.
Which is one over Ndh to the d.
And the sum of the kernel and
the expectation function has been taken inside the sum.
Once we work this out, you can see that the expectation value
is a convolution of the kernel, with the original probability density.
We won't get into more details about the expectation value here.
But we can discuss in the forum why this form is important.
The kernel function we have defined here is known as the Parzen window kernel.
This method is used in signal processing problems.
You will also notice that the smoothness of this PDF depends on the value of h.
We will now look at another kernel known as the Gaussian kernel.